uh i watch the oscars because of the  fabulous dresses  i watch the oscars to see what shoes  everyone is wearing  and who shows up i'm always interested  to see what people are going to wear on  the red carpet  it is such an incredible  thrill when you see people glammed up  having such a good time  i watch the oscars because it's the  super bowl for film nerds  i see it more as the super bowl of  culture oh i like it people are sweating  and they're like nervous it feels like  real life every year i see my friends we  come together and watch the oscars  together and this is really fun i'm  obsessed with watching the oscars and i  do every year and i live in britain so i  stay up all night i can't miss it and i  love it  they're the coolest show ever and now i  get to be a part of them which  makes it cooler for me  it's such a celebration for all we  accomplish on a daily basis  there you go there is pretty good  you